hi everyone uh I'm excited to be here
with you my name is uh Dan Bon I'm a
professor here of computer science I
work on computer security and crypto and
I really welcome this opportunity to
tell you a little a little bit about our
research so thank you for joining the
the webinar and we with that we might as
well get started I have a lot of
material prepared here for you today and
hopefully we'll get through as much of
it as we can I slightly changed the
topic of the of the uh webinar in that
I'm going to tell you a little bit about
the research that we've been doing
recently rather than giving you kind of
a high level overview of uh the field of
cyber security and kind of Bitcoin in
particular um if you want to learn more
um about uh overview issues I'll be
covering I'll be talking about some
courses that we uh teach uh which you're
very very welcome to join okay so with
that let's get started
um so first I wanted to just do a brief
intro of computer security work at
Stanford we have actually a very active
security lab uh there are about eight
faculty who work on computer security I
I kind of uh just threw up their names
over here with the topics that they work
on as you can see we cover all the gamut
from software analysis to crypto web
security verification of protocols
static analysis operating system
security security for The Internet of
Things protocol design and even virtual
machines as they used in security so
there's a very very active um um uh
computer security lab here we also run
uh a security seminar that's open to the
public if you happen to be in the B Bay
Area and you'd like to come attend the
lectures in the security seminar you're
very welcome to do it uh simply go to my
homepage there's a link to our security
seminar just add yourself to the mailing
list and you'll get announcements about
lectures in the security seminar it's a
very low volume mailing list so I would
encourage you to to add yourself
and just be aware of activities that
we're running uh in addition to the
seminar we run occasionally uh various
workshops that generally are open to the
public and you're welcome to attend and
I really look forward to seeing you at
these events as I said just please visit
my web page my homepage and uh there are
instructions there on how to add
yourself to the security uh seminar
mailing list um as you can imagine we do
a lot of uh well we run many courses on
computer security we're kind of uh very
active in security computer security UC
a here at Stanford I just threw up a
list of the courses that we teach as you
can see we're teaching in many different
levels uh there's a freshman seminar
that's uh just covering uh kind of
General ideas in computer security and
then there are courses that are open to
all of you these are courses offered
through the center for professional
development they're for our undergrads
but they're available to you as well uh
so 155 is our main computer security
class it's a very popular class among
our undergraduates and as I said you're
welcome to uh register for that as as
well this fall we're starting a new
course on bitcoin and generally
blockchain
Technologies um we're going to cover um
um basically uh Bitcoin ethereum Stellar
Ripple all those uh different
cryptocurrency techniques as well as um
all the technical issues around them so
this will be a fairly extensive course
I'm not going to cover the material in
the course in this webinar obviously
there's a whole quarter worth of
material on this topic here I'm most
mainly going to talk about research um
things that we've been doing lately and
then we have our crypto course uh 255
again this is a course that uh you're
welcome to sign up for it's for our
undergraduates but again you're welcome
to sign up for it through the center for
professional development and then we
have a number of graduate courses um for
students which again if you'd like to
attend those uh you'd be welcome to uh
to sit in on them uh and finally we have
the uh Advanced computer security
certificate which I'll talk about more
in just a second so as I said uh we're
starting this new Bitcoin course it's
actually starting in the fall quarter so
in just a few weeks uh it will start uh
this is going to be taught by myself
joined with uh Joe BAU uh there's also a
a Hands-On variant of the course uh
where we we're going to teach uh
specifically how to use bit mining
software and we'll be working with uh
one of the Lo local bit mining uh sorry
Bitcoin miners uh to use their systems
uh and learn how to do how to mine
Bitcoin and how to use Bitcoins in
practice so it should be a lot of fun uh
it'll be both both kind of a a technical
description of Bitcoin and also lots of
hands-on
experience um let's see so then finally
as I said we there's also the security
uh uh professional certificate that you
can sign up for there's a website
computer security. stanford.edu that
you're welcome to browse to and learn
more about the Stanford Advanced
computer security certificate all right
so that's so much for our activities in
education uh now let's get down to
business so um what I'm going to talk
about today is as I said more research
topics that we've been working on
recently and I'd love to hear your
comments um either by Q&A here or you
know please send me em mail if um if you
have a particular question about
something that I've said today so I'd
like to start off by talking about some
recent work that we've been doing on on
Bitcoin in particular this question of
how do you prove that that um a Bitcoin
exchange is solvent I'll talk about more
more about that in detail in a minute
then I'll tell you about some work on
mobile security various issues that come
up in um using sensors on phones this
has been kind of fun a fun work for the
past couple of years that we've been
doing and I'd love to tell you about
that and then finally if we have time
I'll wrap up with some very exciting
work that's been happening in the world
of crypto uh recently in the past two
years uh dealing with software aisc I
imagine some of you may have heard of
this and I'll tell you kind of why this
is so exciting to to cryptographers all
right so let's start with our uh
research on bitcoin I guess before I
tell you uh about the work just a very
very very high level overview of Bitcoin
again I imagine many of you know this
and so I'm just going to go through this
very quickly so as you know Bitcoin uses
as it's as an underlying uh primitive
something called a digital signature
just to remind you a digital signature
uh consists of two algorithms there's a
signing algorithm which I'll call sign
and there's a ification algorithm called
verify the signing algorithm generally
uses a secret key that I'll denote by SK
and basically you can use the signing
algorithm to sign any message of your
choice so when you sign a message using
the kyk you obtain a signature uh as a
result and then the verification
algorithm basically takes the
corresponding public key the message and
the signature and decides whether that
signature is a valid signature for the
message under the given public hey so as
I said this is kind of a cryptographic
primitive that's used heavily in uh
Bitcoin in particular Bitcoin uses a
signature scheme called
ecdsa um and so uh what Bitcoin is of
course as you know is a cryptocurrency
that uses uh the blockchain for
consensus and in its simplest form uh
basically you can think of a Bitcoin
address one that uh can receive funds is
essentially kind of a public key that um
is well a public key for a signature
scheme again this isn't it simple form
obviously there are much there are many
many uh variants on what a Bitcoin
address can actually be and the
corresponding secret key for that public
key essentially uh possessing that
secret key in some sense uh indicates
owner of that Bitcoin address and the
secret key is used primarily when when
funds are being transferred from one
address to another so again by signing
uh transfer uh request signning signing
a transaction essentially funds are
being transferred so far so good uh so
again this is just a very very high
level uh description and of course the
issue always with cryptocurrencies is
how do we prevent double spending how do
we make it so that if you own one
Bitcoin and you decide to transfer it to
some other address you cannot then
transfer that Bitcoin that same Bitcoin
to yet another address so this is what
we call the double spending problem we'd
like to prevent that and the way that's
prevented in Bitcoin is using this very
very clever mechanism called a
blockchain which I'm not going to talk
about too much today here I'm actually
really really uh excited about this
blockchain um uh you know the the
blockchain mechanism that was invented
for Bitcoin that's probably one of the
the the most brilliant Innovations um in
the Bitcoin system although there are
many of those and again as you can
imagine you can think of the blockchain
as an append only Ledger it's useful for
the for uh maintaining a cryptocurrency
but it turns out that blockchain
actually has many many applications
beyond the currenc Beyond just the
currency and some since you can almost
think of the cryptocurrency as
motivation as incentive for people to
keep running the blockchain but the
blockchain itself is something that you
can uh write on to and then it can never
be removed so it's kind of an append
only Ledger that everybody agrees on so
there a consensus protocol that uh
ensures that everybody agrees on the
contents of the blockchain and again
once you put something on the blockchain
it can never be removed and that by
itself beyond the currency has a
tremendous number of applications
and so we're actually exploring some of
these applications I think actually a
lot of the excitement around Bitcoin is
exactly uh in the applications of the
blockchain and so for example something
that we're doing here is we're working
with the Stanford registar on uh using
the blockchain to say uh maintain um a
correctness and freshness of academic
records so for example if you have a
transcript we can take or we can clearly
just digitally sign the transcript and
give it to the student the problem is
then if the transcript needs to be needs
to be changed maybe grades have been uh
uh maybe grades have been increased or
or reduced uh somehow the transcript
needs to be changed um it turns out
using the blockchain we can very easily
guarantee that this uh transcript that
the student has really is the latest
version of the transcript so it's kind
of a fresh freshness mechanism that
allows us to update uh transcripts and
that's something that that simply can't
be done just using uh traditional
signatures so here is an example where
the blockchain allows us to do something
that we couldn't do using just
traditional crypto Primitives and so
this is something that we're
implementing now and uh hopefully we'll
get we'll get deployed but more
generally these are uh clearly the the
blockchain is something that can be used
um to manage and maintain records uh
that are supposed to live for a long
time so anyhow that's all I wanted to
say about the blockchain now let's get
to uh one particular uh research project
that we've been working on and that is
that's this question of uh uring
solvency so this is kind of a fun
problem that I wanted to tell you about
as I said I uh the world of Bitcoin at
this point is enormous uh as you can see
we have a whole quarter long course
devoted to it obviously I can't talk
about all the issues in uh surrounding
Bitcoin in in this one webinar and so I
chose to talk about one particular topic
that I thought is kind of fun and so I
hope you'll enjoy it as well so this
question is basically how do we ensure
that a Bitcoin exchange is solvent so
think of a Bitcoin exchange as sort of a
bank and we want to guarantee that the
bank is solvent so what do I mean by
that so I'm going to use the terms uh
Bitcoin exchange and Bank uh
interchangeably but I'll mostly stick to
uh uh calling it a Bitcoin exchange so a
Bitcoin exchange basically has
obligation to its customers so some
customers basically uh deposit their bit
deposit if you like uh their Bitcoins at
this exchange again you can think of it
as a bank but I'll call it an exchange
uh and then uh yes so it has obligations
to its customers these are uh this is
these are actual Bitcoins that were
deposited at this exchange and then the
exchange has assets itself so it owns a
whole bunch of Bitcoin assets um when
what does it mean to own a Bitcoin asset
basically it knows the secret key for
those assets and now we'd like to enable
The Exchange to prove that it's solvent
and when we say prove that it's solvent
what I mean is that uh it likes it would
like to prove that the amount of assets
that it has are clear more than the
obligations that it has to it to its
customers so this is this question of
solvency and I guess I should say that
here I'm just going to address the easy
the simpler problem of proving that the
assets are bigger than the obligations
clearly when it comes to Banks and and
exchanges there's only a need to prove
that say um there's enough Reserve say
the amount of assets is is is you know
half the level of obligations it doesn't
have to be exactly greater than or equal
to but everything I'm going to say uh is
going to generalize to proving that you
have sufficient Reserve to keep the
problem simple I'm just going to talk
about solvency namely that the amount of
assets is bigger than the number of
obligations now what's the technical
challenge here the problem is you'd like
to do it in a way that kind of reveals
nothing to the world about your internal
business namely the uh business of the
exchange so you'd like to reveal nothing
about how much assets The Exchange
actually owns you'd like to reveal
nothing about um the number of customers
or the amount of uh Bitcoin that the
customers have so you'd like to do this
in what's called a zero knowledge Manner
and that I prove to you that in fact my
assets are bigger than my obligations
but you learn nothing else about um uh
yeah about the the um total assets about
sorry the total assets and customers of
this exchange okay good so how the
question is how to do that and so uh
what we've done is we've kind of
actually before I tell you about about
what we've done I should say there's a a
earlier proposal du to Greg Maxwell that
kind of looks at this problem but
doesn't quite solve it in zero knowledge
in the sense that actually some
information about the assets and
obligations is exposed to the outside
world so we were curious whether we can
do this actually in absolute zero
knowledge again we'd like to prove that
the exchange is solvent but without
leaking any other information about what
the exchange has and so we have this
protocol this is Joint work with dagger
bones Joo Clark and myself um that
basically shows how to uh design
basically shows a protocol these are
called zero knowledge protocols that
actually prove that the exchange the
solvent but provably reveal nothing else
about the value of the exchange now you
can imagine actually an exchange um you
know maybe an exchange like uh coinbase
or such you can imagine them running a
protocol like this uh daily uh and so
every day they prove that they're
solvent and of course once they prove
you know on Thursday that they solvent
they can throw away the proof that
they've done on Wednesday so just keep
the latest Pro proof to say that every
day they're solvent and if certain
exchanges well you've probably heard of
Mount gox if an exchange like Mount gox
had done something like this they would
have this would actually uh alerted
people that there are troubles in monx
much earlier far earlier than uh um you
know when the problems were actually
discovered so again the goal here is to
show enable The Exchange to prove that
it's solvent but do it without revealing
any information about the inner workings
of the exchange so the question is how
do we do this and so the protocol that
we have is divided into three
subprotocols and I'm going to explain
this to you at a very very high level as
I said this kind of gets a little
technical uh to get into the actual
details if you'd like to read more about
this there's a paper that's available on
our website um so that you can see how
the details actually work uh but let me
just show you at a high level how the
protocol actually works so the
fundamental building block that you're
that we're using are what what's called
uh cryptographic commitments so I can
create when I say I I mean the exchange
can create a commitment to a certain
value publishing the commitment reveals
nothing about the value and yet the
exchange is bound to the value that it
committed to so I can commit to the
number 17 you will not know that I've
that the commitment that I published is
a commitment to 17 but I can only open
the commitment to show you that what's
in it is the number 17 so I'll refer to
the number 17 as the value of the
commitment again I publish the
commitment the commitment reveal reveals
nothing to you and yet I'm committed
committed to the value of the commitment
the the value that's embedded in the
commitment so subprotocol number one
basically allows the exchange to create
a commitment to the total obligations
that it has so what do I mean by that
the commitment basically binds The
Exchange to the total number of assets
that its customers have so this would be
a very could be a very large number of
Bitcoins and yet the commitment reveals
nothing about about the actual assets
that the um that its customers have and
yet the uh The Exchange is bound to the
value that it committed to now the idea
is once the exchange commits to say you
know I uh my obl my total obligations is
you know however many uh Bitcoins every
user can actually uh well every user is
actually given some sort of a secret
that allows the user to go and verify
that its balance is actually included in
the commitment that the exchange
published so that's kind of an
interesting concept there that the Comm
the exchange can publish a commitment
that commitment allows any user of the
exchange any customer of the exchange to
verify that its balance was actually
included in the commitment and so if a
large enough fraction of the customers
actually do the test do this check that
kind of suggests uh there you know gives
us some confidence that really the uh
committed value really does encompass
the the total obligation
that the exchange has so that's sub
protocol number one again if you want to
see how this works or why this is secure
I would direct you to the paper so now
that we have a commitment to the
obligation let's call this commitment o
right so again the Val the the
commitment itself reveals nothing about
the obligations um but the value inside
the commitment is the actual obligation
and the and the exchange is committed to
that value the next step is to create a
commitment to the asset the total assets
that the exchange has and again we want
to do it in a way that doesn't reveal uh
how much how many assets The Exchange
actually has this is a harder problem
and so let me show you how how we deal
with this so what we do is basically we
have the exchange kind of look at uh
public keys that are already published
on the blockchain so these would be uh
uh Bitcoin addresses that are already
published on the blockchain and those um
addresses actually have balances
associated with them yeah so there
there's actual funds available or
Associated uh with those addresses and
so what the exchange will do is it's
going to pick a whole bunch of public
keys but it's going to know so sorry and
this set of public Keys here is going to
include the public keys that the
exchange has that the exchange owns but
there are many more public Keys here
than uh the public that the exchange
actually owns so just give you an
example you can imagine there's like
maybe a million public Keys um uh
embedded here a million sort of Bitcoin
addresses included here but maybe the
exchange only owns you know 1% of those
or 10% of those so it only owns a subset
of those and what does it mean to own a
subset well it knows the secret key for
only a subset of the addresses that it
chose to include in this list pk1 to pkn
now yes so we have we call this list pk1
to pkn we call it the anonymity set so
it's an anonymity set that includes a
large number of addresses and the
exchange only owns a subset of those
addresses now what the exchange is going
to do is it's going to prove that the
sum of balances um of these public keys
so the sum of balances for that it owns
namely for which it knows the secret key
is in fact the value that's in the
commitment to its assets okay so this is
a little bit tricky to kind of think
about how this works but basically
you're kind of proving that you know the
secret key for a subset of pk1 to pkn
and if you sum up the balances for the
public keys for which you know the
secret key in fact what you'll get is
the value that's embedded in the
commitment to the
assets okay so I hope that's clear I
know it's a little abstract uh but I
hope it's clear and you can look again
at the paper to see exactly how that's
implemented and the point is uh now now
by looking at this proof you can of
you're kind of convinced that in fact um
the total assets that the uh exchange
has is in fact uh the value that's
committed to by the commitment a but you
still have no no idea which addresses
The Exchange actually owns so you know
the exchange owns a certain subset of
these addresses but you learn nothing
about which addresses it owns okay so
this is a way for the uh exchange to
prove that it owns a certain set of
assets without actually telling you
which addresses belong to the exchange
and which don't okay and again there are
like like I said there are many many
many technical aspects that come up here
I hope some of you are already thinking
of all sorts of obstacles that um come
up when you try to secure a protocol
like this um there like I said there are
many many issues that come up and we
kind of discussed many of these issues
uh in the paper so I would encourage you
to kind of look at it it's actually kind
of an interesting interesting problem
and who knows maybe if you look at this
problem and you think about it some more
yourself you'll come up with even better
Solutions than the one that we have I
would kind of challenge you uh to try
and come up with a better solution I
think it's a beautiful problem and it
would be nice uh to have improvements so
the last step now that we have a
commitment to the obligations and we
have a commitment to the assets the last
step is to prove solvency namely just
prove that the value that's embedded in
the commitment to the assets is in fact
greater than the value in the
commitments to the obligations and in
terms that this is actually not an
interesting problem this is actually
solved we're just using a standard
comparison protocol here so this is not
uh not our contribution uh kind of
protocols one and two are kind of the
main technical aspects of the work so
again as I said I think it's kind of a
fun fun uh problem to think about um if
you are if you like these kind of
problems you know please please think
about it and I'm sure you'll be able to
improve over what we did um cuz as I as
I can imagine there's lots and lots of
more research to be done here okay so
you know we went ahead and implemented
this and experimented with it so just
let me just uh report on running times
so you can see that for example if the
anonymity set is 500,000 keys so you use
500,000 addresses to hide um what your
where what your assets are then what
what these what this graph shows here is
that uh well let's see if I can parse
this for you so constructing the proof
takes about you know 15 minutes this is
on a single laptop uh actually it's kind
of a dinky laptop so with more power
probably you can do it faster uh but
anyhow constructing the proof takes
about 15 minutes um so that's definitely
something that an exchange can do every
day uh the size of the proof is about
well you know it's it's big but not too
big the size of the proof is about a
gigabyte so it can publish that gigabyte
uh and have people verify pieces of it
verifying the the entire proof takes
about 40 minutes but not everybody has
to verify the entire proof you know
different people different customers can
verify different parts of the proof uh
and so this is definitely something that
that an exchange can do every day just
publish it you know every day they will
spend 15 minutes generating this proof
publish the gigabyte somewhere people
can download fragments of the proof and
locally verify parts of it and if ever
someone uh finds a mistake in the proof
or the exchange is not able to complete
the proof this would actually mean the
exchange is not solvent and boom the
minute that happens you catch the fact
that it lost soleny and then you can
react so again this would give
confidence more confidence in exchanges
it's to me this sounds like it's
actually something that could be uh used
today and so hopefully um some of you
would be interested in using it but like
I said the reason I'm describing this is
to encourage more research in the area
so hopefully that's uh something you
would want to look at and and try to
come up with better Solutions yourself
all right very good so that's what I
wanted to say about uh Bitcoin as I said
there's a tremendous number of things we
could talk about in the space of Bitcoin
I just wanted to give you like one cute
problem that uh we we've been working on
and as I said you know uh the the entire
course that we're going to be running in
the fall will explore the whole Space of
problems that uh come up the whole Space
of issues and applications that come up
in the area of Bitcoin so I hope to see
you there so let's see so I have a few
minutes left I'd like to tell you a
little bit more about other work that
we're doing uh more generally in
Security in particular I'll tell you
about some work that we've been doing on
mobile security in particular sensors on
mobile devices and this is Joint work uh
with my student Yan mvi and our
collaborator gabin abli all right so
let's start with um with this with with
what we're doing here so essentially as
you know smartphones have lots and lots
and lots of sensors on them it's really
quite remarkable how this tiny device
can have so many smartphones right so
there a microphone a camera a GPS a
light sensor a compass and so on and so
forth and as it turns out some of these
sensors actually seem like they have no
security implications at all and so any
application on your phone is actually
allowed to read these sensors this is at
least in the Android space without
actually requiring any permission in
particular uh your phone has a gyroscope
and in fact any application can read a g
gyroscope and you know what harm could
possibly come from the gyroscope so
there's not a lot of per there are no
permissions required to read it um
similarly and again I'm talking about
Android here iPhone is a different story
and similarly on Modern phones uh there
is a power meter that's been uh added to
the phone so applications can measure
how much power is being drawn off the
battery in any given moment and that
allows them to scale their operations if
they see that too much power is being
drawn at any given at any given time and
again these are accessible without uh
requiring any particular permissions and
so the question is you know do these uh
sensors that seem completely innocuous
uh you know are there security
implications to to uh their inclusion in
the phone in particular can they be
abused so whenever you know a security
person asks you can something be abused
you know the answer is always yes and so
let's see what can we do with these
sensors so I'll just give you a few
examples um the first example is this
question of can we build a hardware
fingerprint of the device Yeah so
basically this is something that um an
application might want to do it wants to
basically identify the device in a way
that if if it ever gets reinstalled on
the device at a later time it could tell
that it's actually being installed on a
device that it's already seen before you
can imagine maybe someone is um maybe
misbehaving and being blocked out of a
service later on the user might just
uninstall and reinstall the application
the application would like to know hey
this is a device I've already seen
before and it belongs to a person that
was already blocked for some reason for
one reason or another so this is a way
to build kind of a stable fingerprint of
a device there was already earlier work
on this really beautiful work that
showed that imper imperfections in the
camera sensor can actually be used to
link pictures to a particular phone okay
so just every phone obviously has a
camera But the lens are not exactly
lenses are not exactly the same so the
lens on my phone is slightly different
from the lens on your phone then it
turns out these imperfections in the
lens can actually be used to link
multiple pictures to tell that all these
pictures were taken by the same phone so
we're going to do the same thing except
we're going to do it to uh the
accelerometer so it turns out again
every accelerometer in you in you know
phones have accelerometers they're
typically used for games right so as you
play a racing game you can imagine kind
of moving the phone up and down and um
the game then using the accelerometer
can tell exactly at what angle you're
you're holding up your phone and that's
helpful for gaming so you know what
could possibly go wrong by using the
accelerometer well it turns out the
accelerometer in my phone has slight
imperfections as compared to the
accelerometer in your phone these are
all below the manufacturing tolerances
so very very small minor imperfections
and what we can do is once you have an
application on your phone we can
actually measure the imperfections in
your accelerometer and it turns out
those imperfections actually give a
fairly stable device fingerprint so we
can identify y your phone from a large
set of phones simply by the
imperfections in your accelerometer now
I want to emphasize that this is some
this is a fingerprint that even if you
reset to your phone and reinstall the
operating system and reinstall all the
applications you can't get rid of the
fingerprint right the application can
just remeasure the uh imperfections in
your accelerometer and that gives you a
stable device ID that can identify your
phone so obviously this device ID can
then be sent to the cloud and the cloud
can say ah this is a phone that I've
already seen before and I know who it
belongs to so this is again a way to
kind of track phones using a device
fingerprint and you know it's just good
to realize that these things are
possible by uh using uh these sensors um
and so uh you know good to know that the
that that it is possible to build uh
stable device IDs so if we don't want to
allow applications to build device IDs
somehow we have to block access to these
sensors okay so that's just one quick
example let's look at more interesting
examples so as you know again phones
have these gyron gyron pick up
vibrations on the phone and again these
vibrations are used primarily used for G
for gaming so that I can kind of very
accurately measure how the user is
holding up his phone so that allow that
you know helps uh with um playing games
on on on phones of course the problem is
these gyroscopes are extremely sensitive
EX sensitive in particular they're so
sensitive that they can pick up actually
air vibrations so if you put the phone
down on a desk and well you talk speech
causes air vibration and it turns out
that uh the the gyop is sensitive enough
to actually pick pick up these
vibrations now you can sample the gyron
at about 200 htz and that's actually too
low rate for human speech so if you
actually play the sound that comes out
of out out of the gyr to the human ear
it sounds like Gish so we can't actually
humans cannot actually identify what's
being said based on such a low uh low
frequency sample but of course machines
can be trained to recognize speech and
in fact using machine learning we were
able to show that certain words can
actually be recognized so in effect
What's Happening Here is the gyroscope
which was added to the phones for the
purposes of games all of a sudden can be
used as a microphone so we call this a
gyop and again the reason to point this
out is that access to the microphone
obviously is very well protected
applications should not have access to
the microphone unless the user gives
explicit permission for that and yet
access to the to the gyop to the
gyroscope is unprotected and basically
what we show is that in fact the
gyroscope can in some sense be used as a
microphone so there's kind of an in
inconsistency in security policies here
so again if you want to prevent that you
had better make sure that access to the
gyop phone is not just given to anyone
somehow how more protection has to be
applied to the gyr we'll talk about
defenses in just a minute okay so that's
the second example I wanted to show you
the third example is again this is
another this is a second example of kind
of use of unintended consequences of
these sensors the third example I want
to show you is the power meter and again
power meters were recently added to
phones so the Nexus 5 the Nexus 6 all
have power meters and again you can see
why you want to add a power meter to
your phone uh basically it allows applic
to tell how much power is being drawn
off the battery in any given time and
again that allows them to scale back
operations if they see that a lot of
power is being drawn great so it allows
them to optimize power use so what can
possibly wrong go wrong how can you
possibly abuse the power sensor well so
let me show you one example of how the
power sensor can be abused well as it
turns out um your phone obviously has a
wireless radio embedded in it and when
it's talking to the the cell tower say
you're driving in a car here when your
phone is talking to the cell tower the
amount of power that your radio uses
depends on obstructions between your car
and the cell tower so for example when
um there are no obstructions you know
there's a direct line of sights then in
fact your uh your your cell phone uh
radio doesn't use a whole lot of power
but if all of a sudden there is an
obstruction say there's a tree or
building all of a sudden your power your
radio has to scale up the amount of
power it's using and that generates
obviously uh more that draws more power
from the from the battery well so what
that means if you think about that what
it means is as you drive down the street
so right so your phone is in your car
and our our app is running on your phone
as you drive down the street essentially
you get a nice power fingerprint that's
specific to that street so you can see
here there was very little power drawn
so probably L cleared on a site to the
cell tower all of a sudden there's a
jump in power so probably uh you know
the car just just went in front of a
building and now the the phone has to
use the radio has to use much more power
to uh to reach the cell tower and then
again once you um uh Drive behind the
building again there's very little power
being drawn and by the way this is
actually um a picture from two different
devices so that you can see this is not
just one particular device uh this is
actually consistent across different
devices and in fact it's consist
consistent across different days so we
drove when I say we I mean my students
drove around um around the city you can
see across days you get kind of the same
power graph no matter um uh no matter
what phone you're using no matter what
time you're driving you get kind of a
very similar graph aha so what this
suggests is that in fact as as you drive
down the road um essentially well
actually what an attacker can do is kind
of build a power fingerprint for
different roads in the US and then as
you drive down the road the attacker can
correlate the power signature that
you're generating currently with the
power signature that the attacker
measured maybe uh sometime in advance
and that basically tells the attacker
what road you're on so another way to
say it is basically again if you have
power readings from the past and you
have power readings from the that are
currently being being used by the phone
it turns out with enough machine
learning and there's actually quite a
lot of work that had to be done to make
this work you can essentially identify
where the phone is so the power meter
effectively acts as a GPS system so
again G access to the GPS is clearly
very well controlled and protected and
yet we show that by giving unmitigated
access to the power meter essentially
you turn the power meter into a GPS and
so here there's just a graph that shows
um that as you driving on a particular
route this just happens to be 101 in the
Bay Area as you're driving down a
particular Street the app can identify
fairly accurately uh where you are it's
not perfect as you notice it's a little
bit off but you know still it can kind
of identify where you are along a
particular route and there again many
many more examples in the paper this is
just to give you kind of a taste of what
um what this thing can do so why are we
doing all this well the answer is you
know obviously it's better to know that
these things are possible than to not
know you know knowledge is always a good
thing but primarily we'd like to prevent
this kind of privacy risk and so the
first message is every time you add a
sensor or every time anyone adds a
sensor to a phone the sensor typically H
sensors typically have these unintended
consequences and can can leak
information about the phone that you
never intend into and the question is
how to prevent this well one option is
always to require permissions that
applications would always have to ask
for permission uh to access a particular
centor um asking for permission is
always clearly not ideal because users
might not realize what they're granting
what permissions they're granting here
but really access to the power meter
should be viewed as access to the GPS
access to the gyr to gyroscope should
should be viewed as ask access to the
microphone and operating systems should
take as much care as granting access to
those sensors as they would to the
microphone and G and the GPS
alternatively you might try to reduce
the amount of information that
applications can gather from these
sensors in particular you might actually
only try to give them abstract view of
data rather than the specific view that
you know very raw detail view that
they're able to get today so there lot
there's also lots of work I'm trying to
prevent these types of attacks but again
I guess I we are running short on time
so I guess I will stop here so let me
just mention that the last thing I was
going to tell you about was kind of
recent excitement in the area of crypto
and I was tell you going to tell you a
little bit about software Al fisc but I
think we're running out out of time so
I'll just mention that we have an NSF
funded center it's called a center for
encrypted functionalities studies how to
do cryptographic software application
there's been a lot of exciting
developments in that space in the last
two years if you just search uh Google
for that uh for this phrase you'll find
the center and there's a lot of details
on what's happening there and so I will
hand it over back to Stacy here and it's
been fun and exciting for me to uh speak
with you today and I hope to hear from
you and see you uh at some point in the
future thank you very much yeah I guess
there's a question on um whether there's
a way in which the exchange can somehow
uh make it look like it has more assets
than it uh
should
um well you know as I said I kind of
gave a very brief overview of the
construction it turn there are actually
lots and lots and lots of attacks you
might imagine about a system like this
um and we as I said we kind of addressed
those in the paper um as it turns out
essentially every time you commit to to
an obligation as I said a customer is
going to verify that um uh that his that
his account was actually included in the
obligations and one risk is of course
that
um uh The Exchange might try to might
try to use uh a
commitment let's say might try to show
two customers a commitment to the same
value um in which case um you know
you'll get the wrong the the actual
wrong uh sum the wrong obligation sum as
it turns out you know the construction
specifically prevents that from
happening so when you look at the uh
commitments to obligations um each
obligation corresponds to exactly the
balance of one account so there's no way
in which two accounts can be counted
once I hope I I'm understanding the
question here uh and I hope that answers
it so there is actually um usernames
committed usernames in these commitments
to obligations and that ensures that you
cannot commit to two different accounts
under the same commitment so kind of
have the same quantities be you be used
to cover two different accounts I hope
that answers the question I'm not sure
uh I'm not sure I quite understood uh
the issue but uh I guess we will leave
it there let's
see yeah so let's see another question
is does any of the course go over
applying biometric security to cyber
security you know so biometric security
is is basically can be used as an
authentication system that is relevant
to bitcoin because if you are if you
want to secure a Bitcoin wallet you
could imagine using biometric security
uh to enhance security of a Bitcoin
wallet so we'll discuss this briefly in
the Bitcoin course but I have to say
that biometric security is something
that we mostly discuss in the in the
security class because biometric
security is more General than just
Bitcoin and um yeah so that's actually
something that we mostly discuss in the
security
class uh yeah there's a question a
general question here is what's the
difference in tech details between
courses in the graduate program and the
professional
program uh is that a question for you I
I can answer this I have to say that uh
our oncampus courses they are 10 10 we
courses three hour with three hours of
lecture a week so there's actually quite
a lot of material in our oncampus
courses our professional program are is
is not as as are not as long um and so
obviously we can't go into as much
detail and so the professional program
is for someone who wants to quickly get
information about a particular topic
there's obviously quite a lot of detail
in the professional program but I have
to say that our oncampus courses uh go
deeper just because we have more time
well basically we have the students for
10 weeks so we can give more homeworks
more projects um and as a result uh
there they actually is more detail in
the on-campus uh
courses in addition to enrollment as
well there's regular enrollment um
admission processes for the graduate
courses and the advanced computer
security certificate is um also an
applications but not nearly as
technical great thanks Stacy uh let's
see so there uh there's another question
on homomorphic encryption so there's
some exciting advances on homomorph
homomorphic encryption can you comment
on the current state-ofthe-art
um that's a that's a great question so
homomorphic encryption is something that
allows you to do arbitrary computations
on Cipher texts without actually knowing
what the PL text is um and so there's
actually been quite a lot of work on
trying to get homomorphic encryptions to
be more practical the current state of
art is very simple there's a oneline
simple answer there's a you know an one
a one hour long answer I'll give you the
oneline simple answer which is that
effectively there's a system out of San
Diego UCSD that shows that you can
evaluate one gate one logical gate per
one second that's the state-ofthe-art in
fully homomorphic encryption so one gate
per 1 second obviously would compare the
this to an Intel processor which does
like three billion gates in one second
and that gives you the rate of slowdown
from for fic encryption so it's about 10
to the 7 at this point there's actually
a more complicated answer which is if
you are trying to do a competition
that's very am minable to
parallelization you can actually speed
things up more but the rough uh um
estimate these days is as I said about
an order of 10 to the 7 slowdown over
computations on clear text this is
already better than when things started
um but this is where we are
today oh there's a beautiful question
here on is there a way to provide early
warning on solvency issues um so the
system that I described to you basically
gives you a way to discover that when an
exchange has become insolvent but in
some sense that's too late right the
money money is already gone so the
question here is is there a way to kind
of uh identify insolvency early on so
that's actually a great question I think
that deserves um more study it's not
exactly clear what technically what that
means you somehow have to predict the
future that an exchange will become
insolvent in sub Point although maybe
you can use the fact that it it it's
involved in certain contracts that might
make an insolvent um and that's
something that you can identify so I
think this is a really nice question and
to be honest this is room for future
work absolutely today the protocol only
identifies the issues once when um once
once the exchange become becomes
insolvent it would be great to maybe go
over contracts that the exchange is
involved and and try to predict where
it's headed I should I should mention
though that it that insolvency is
generalized to reserve as I said so the
exchange can prove that its assets are
at most half the obligations or on10th
the obligations so you can imagine
having kind of a sliding bar where um it
can decide on what reserve it wants to
to prove and then it can prove that it
actually has that that
reserve and so maybe a way to capture
insolvency is by asking the uh exchange
to Pro to do the proof for different
values of the reserve and if it can
prove um uh solve you know reserve for
one value but not for another maybe
that's some sort of of an early warning
sign but more generally it would be
great to generalize a system to deal
with uh smart contracts and um identify
future possible insolvency that's a
really really nice question yeah there's
someone asking about sensors and iot
devices will these defenses be
implemented into iot devices I think
that's another beautiful question in
that um you know the the the the world
of Internet of Things is really only
just starting there is at this point the
industry is mostly focusing on deploying
and building Internet of Things uh
devices and there have already been a
number of studies that show that there
are you know major security issues with
the with these inter internet things
devices starting from um support for
software updates where the updates
themselves are not signed so anyone can
uh write software updates for these
things going on to uh standard kind of
uh uh security vulnerabilities even
programming and memory corruption
attacks um so the state of security in
The Internet of Things is somewhat
problematic at this point um especially
specifically because of the rush to
Market and the need to build these
devices as as fast as possible
I should say that um one of our faculty
Phil Levis who was part of the security
lab started a project on specifically on
studying the security of Internet of
Things the goal there is to provide some
sort of um software platform where
Internet of Things developers can build
on the software software platform and
they would they would have um at least
in terms of configuration and um
programming style at least there would
be some security built in for example
software updates would always be signed
so it would be impossible for someone to
um um inject a malicious software update
into the device so yeah I think the
security in in The Internet of Things is
a fantastic area of research um I hope
well again I hope some of you will get
involved oh there's a question of how to
get more info on our research on cell
phone security mobile security in
general you know everything that I
talked about today is available on our
website so if you just go to my website
you'll see uh all the research we do is
in the public in the in the public
domain uh public domain so if you just
go to to our websites and look at our
Publications you'll find all the papers
that I
mentioned oh actually there's another
fantastic question here about can uh can
the blockchain and open- Source
processes be used for uh for internet
management like I can functionalities in
fact there is a wonderful wonderful uh
idea for um managing DNS uh ownership
through the blockchain so this is an
example of kind of moving more internet
management functionality over to the
blockchain so the blockchain as I said
I'm actually really excited about
applica non-currency applications of the
blockchain um there's really uh you know
the the the number of applications is is
is kind of Staggering at this point once
we have sort of a ledger that everyone
can write to and information can never
be removed it can be used for so many
different things sort of the DNS
application here where you can prove you
can prove ownership of a domain by
putting this um certificate of ownership
onto the blockchain that's uh an
instance of a more general idea where
you can prove you can prove ownership of
assets um you know cars homes internet
domains email addresses public Keys um
and as I mentioned uh even academic
transcripts you can prove that all those
things sort of Belong To You by having
them placed in some one way or another
in the blockchain there are lots of
interesting uh zero knowledge issues and
privacy issues that come up in doing
that there's um one one of my post talks
Joe Bono has uh worked on a a system
called conx that kind of uh goes in that
direction if you look for that uh you
can find more information about that um
and so I think that's a that's a
fantastic area of research again many
many potential applications for using
the blockchain for managing ownership
and and other types of
Records great thank you Dan um on behalf
of the Stanford center for professional
development I'd like to thank you for
joining us today on our webinar on
bitcoin and cyber security we have
recorded this session and we'll post it
um within a week um I know there have
been a number of questions on enrollment
process and requirements again the two
recommended websites that I checked just
based on your interest would be the scpd
website which is SC
cd. stanford.edu
on that page you can find information on
both actually the um graduate courses
and the professional education however
if you're looking for just targeted
information on the um Advanced computer
security um professional certificate you
can find that at computer security.
stanford.edu thank you everyone have a
wonderful
day